I mean I I think every film really uh
well if it's a good film it's sharing
some kind of point of view it's sharing
some message it's sharing some Human
Experience even even secular films like
they have something that they are
there's a message that they're trying to
convey very intentional in some way or
the other and and that's because that's
the that's the strongest Avenue to
really convince people where else will
people put their phone down for 90
minutes or more and pay attention to
your worldview
undistracted welcome to Leed live it's a
show where we use the Light of Christ to
expose the darkness found in media and
our culture and today we have a guest
Kevin Christensen thank you so much for
joining us on the show thank you for
having me yeah so Kevin is the head of
Hope Studios and we're going to delve
into that what that's all about but
first we'd like to hear your story as to
what birthed your interest in film to
begin with well um I was I was born and
raised in a Christian household um so I
I grew up um you know as a Believer and
following um the greatest Storyteller of
all time and I saw the power that
stories had with reaching people and
kind of that experiential Journey that
that gives people hope that gives people
faith that um you know exposes light and
darkness um and and that's and such a
power powerful tool and so when I um
when I went to college I got involved
with a traveling drama company and and
we did we did Productions um for a lot
ofies and schools kind of Youth rally
weekend things uh was a Christian drama
company and um but I was but I was
always kind
of uh discouraged from like making it a
career you know I was like oh that's a
hobby you know exactly yeah like you got
to get a real job kid you know so I was
like okay all right well this is my
hobby so I like did like business school
by day and then like you know acting
storytelling writing by night and um and
then we also started up a sketch uh
sketch comedy show while we were there
in college and and it was just a lot of
fun and I don't know I just caught this
I caught this bug um there's something
just amazing about bringing people into
that experience taking them on a journey
and you know we all know the heroes
Journey it's like take you where you are
we all have a challenge we overcome that
and we better on the other side um and
so you know finding those ways to reach
people um I think I think I just think
that that's that's so cool so I kind of
caught that bug in college doing that
production stuff and then I got to the
end of college and it was like real
world got to get an actual job you know
and I was like oh man Ming to Hollywood
yeah yeah and I and I so I did the
cheaper version of that which was
yollywood in Atlanta yeah went down to
went down to Atlanta and uh you know I
just started doing background work kind
of what I didn't know anybody in um in
the industry really and so I kind of
took whatever background roles I could I
could get it was a chance to just get in
the room be on set see how things are
done um and it gave me a very different
perspective also on on the industry
because I'd never really seen behind the
curtain I'd always seen the final
product and um it's really slow and
boring it is it's hurry up and wait yeah
exactly were you doing extra work yeah I
started off doing you will do there for
10 hours work one were you in any of the
Marvel stuff they fled through Atlanta
and they did yeah yeah I wor I did work
on um Captain America Civil War that was
that was like one of the first projects
that I I got to be an extra on so
they're one soldier running across yeah
if you like if you like pause one one
spot you can like see my back maybe or
something see my B shining in the
backround of the change of yeah exactly
well that experience were you
intentional about that like oh I want to
get this kind of I want to be in this
environment or you just taking whatever
you can get you you kind of take you
kind of take whatever you can get
because uh you know when you're yeah and
when you're and when you're starting you
know Beggars can't be choosers um with
things and and it's interesting because
I have these conversations on more of
like a philosophical theological level
sometimes with people that are like well
you know why would people maybe work on
certain projects that you don't agree
with or you know um you know why why
don't you do this I prefer this style or
this genre and I feel like that's better
than that one when you start you don't
really get to choose all the projects
that you're working on I mean and a lot
of times you don't even know necessarily
what the script is or what I mean it's
kind of you know you're kind of a gun
for hire with that stuff and so I sort
of equate that to well you can't walk
into a company and say hi I want to run
all your marketing and tell you how
you're going to speak to people they're
like you're going to take the front desk
position and you're going what you're
assigned to do and you know and
hopefully if you um you know if you're
if you're a good Steward and you are
working for the Lord as if you're
working for the Lord not men even though
you're working for men yeah hold your
principles um you know Daniel had to
work in Babylon before he got the
opportunity to say okay now I'm going to
influence it right so I think that
there's opportunities and and there's
cautions amongst that like there are
things that you you will know ahead of
time and especially with actors um they
have to disclose if there are like nude
scenes they don't want people getting
surprised by that um they have to
disclose if there's if there's going to
be things that Society has accepted as
like that might be risque it might you
know hurt you down the line with your
career because they also don't want to
end up in a situation where an actor
shows up everyone's ready to go and they
go surprise you're doing a nude scene
and they're like no I'm not and then it
throws everything off yeah so you know
you don't always know necessarily what
the what the script is going to have in
terms of details and things like that um
but if you're an actor you're going to
know if you're going to be in
compromising situations and for actors
they'll see this they'll see the script
but even then they may only see the
scenes that they're in especially like
Marvel stuff because they want to keep
it so secret they write they write
alternative Scripts so a lot of people
have fake scripts and only enough of the
information yeah it's it's very crazy
like they they worked that out 10 years
prior to shooting I remember seeing like
this whole behind the scenes and it was
like they had down to I mean the
computer generated Graphics of where the
camera was going to be and everything to
the point where it was like handing
somebody a recipe for making bread or
something follow this and that was that
the movie was I mean it's it's the
detail that they they get is crazy yeah
so so um you know your experience of
working um as an extra yeah you don't
get a chance to choose on it and yeah so
I moved up from being an extra to what's
called a standin for actors where when
you're setting up the scenes um it can
take a long time to set the shots up and
so you need to practice you know well
what if what if we have the camera here
but then we have you know them standing
here and then we have extras passing by
oh well see from that angle we're
blocking so actually let's have the
extras over here you know and you need
to you need to test your lighting and
all and that's why every you know every
film you you pause and it looks like a a
picture right because it was so
intentionally framed but that takes a
lot of setup so if you have actors there
and they're under the lights and they're
having to practice here and there tired
they get exhausted and and you really
want the best performance when they're
fresh so they bring in standin and so
standin are roughly the same height same
skin complexion for lighting uh hair
color you know a lot of the same
features they'll put them in the same
clothes as the actors and then they'll
usually have some kind of a name tag so
it's you know standing for so and so so
you were Fabio yes so clearly clearly
you know with with my hair and uh and
and skills uh so so I got to stand in
yeah for for some actors and that that
kind of brought me over on to the crew
side of things where now I'm actually
working with the director and and the ad
and and the crew side of people and I
did get to meet some of the actors and
um you know people are like did you did
you meet famous people I'm like I If you
stand in for them yes you're usually at
a certain position by the time you have
a stand in so it's one step up from
being extra you get more pay and stuff
right you do you do you get to eat at
the better lunch line it's a little it's
a little nicer it's nothing to write
home about but you know it's it is it is
pretty cool so and it was a great
networking opportunity for me because
now I got to talk with people like
producers assistants and other people
that are coming up and so you know what
I found is um there's this great quote
that says uh um luck is the intersection
of preparation and timing yeah and so
you know what I saw in college was I saw
a lot of film Majors who were doing all
the preparation but they were never
putting themselves in the situation to
have the timing so they might have some
of the greatest films stories to tell
but they're never around people that
would see it and then on the flip side
in Atlanta I saw people that you know
they had these resumes where they're
working on Marvel movies they're working
on DC shows they're working on Max
content they're working on Paramount
movies but they're always like assisting
this and assisting that and they don't
have something to show for themselves
when they say well I really want to be a
writer well what' you write uh well I
was an assistant to a that doesn't mean
you a writer right you know I was the
assistant to the director yeah but what
did you direct so through some of those
connections I I found some really
quality people that said hey we're we're
looking to move up we realize we're
going to need that um kind of showcase
to give so in their spare time they
would go and hire all the other people
that that they'd worked with that also
had that same mindset hey the assistant
camera guy who wants to be a Director of
Photography you want to direct you know
the you want to shoot our our project
this yeah yeah I'd love that hey the
assistant director who really wants to
direct you want to yeah yeah yeah the
the you know build producers assistant
you want to you know and so that gave
everyone kind of a chance to do that and
that's how I got to network and kind of
move up so then I moved up to an uh
executive producers assistant and then
where I worked out at Tyler Perry
Studios on a show for that and that gave
me a a kind of Crash Course 30,000 foot
view of like oh now I see the work done
during the day in the production office
before you like go to set and everything
that happens there and then um during Co
I started doing assistant manager
manager supervisor positions until
eventually I moved into my position as
head of Hope studios Okay so to set up
this next question can you just explain
to our audience what what's the role of
a producer in a film uh miscellaneous
get it done yeah all the above can you
do it all the above so you know I sort
of equate that in the corporate world to
maybe a project manager uh or a
supervisor um but
basically yeah it's kind of you know the
buck stops with you and you're
responsible for your project for your
film and it may be in different
capacities there's lots of different
types of producers um in the same way
that there's like lots of different
types of account accountants right
you've got your CPAs you've got your
corporate accountants you've got your um
uh your you know accountants that are
looking specifically with fraud or tax
account well the same kind of thing with
with producers so you'll have creative
producers and they may be people that
are brought in to really help you know
finesse the storyline and the
storytelling they've got good
connections with writers um or or
Consultants that they can bring in to
make the story more real more accurate
you have your line producers those are
really just looking at the bottom line
of things um and they're dealing with
all the all the finances you have
executive producers that may they may
just be someone with a large check you
know but you can't do it without them
you know and so or sometimes you get
executive producers where you know the
movie may not get picked up unless you
have a recognizable celebrity attached
to a list talent and so an executive
producer might get their credit simply
by saying I'll tell you what you bring
me on board I bring on EX actor or
actress and they get on board with that
so there's a lot of different types of
producers with that specifically with
with our film The hopeful um I served as
one of the executive producers on that
so I I found this the um the director
for it we had connected a number of
years back he had the story and I
brought that to the studio to say hey I
think this is what we should do um you
know and there's lots of other people
that have to approve it and sign off and
things like that because then I'm also
talking to the person who gets the
financing for it and brings that in and
then I'm talking to legal and getting
the sign offs from that and now that
we're at the point of distribution then
I'm in a lot of the distribution
meetings you know making sure hey is
this still on brand with what we want to
do and talking to the grassroot side of
things and so I'm kind of a bit of an
Orchestra conductor of like we have so
many you know the the tuba and the flute
over here are going and that's your
marketing and that's your legal side but
then you have creative and then you have
you know PR and you've got financing
over here and so there's all those
pieces that you're kind of conducting
the orchestra with so then I'm curious
comparing the the experiences of an
actor versus a producer and and their
responsibilities and with the experience
of the actor kind of you kind of at a
certain stage take what you can get to
eat and all these things how how how do
the experiences are they similar or are
they different in terms of someone
wanting to keep their autonomy in this
industry well the best way to keep your
autonomy is to do Tik Tok you know the
more of a team that you get the more
you're going to have to navigate other
creative opinions entering in there so
you know the moment that you get someone
to write you a check for something you
there's strings attached to those checks
um even even in donor models you still
have a lot of strings attached sometimes
even more to those checks um so you know
you bring a writer in they're going to
bring some perspectives of their own
that you have to navigate a director
their perspect so the more that you're
within a team the more that you're going
to have to navigate those things um but
you would have more flexibility as a
producer than say an actor when they're
like you
this is the contract you kind of have to
do this if you say no then we're going
to find something else versus a producer
you may be able to change some things
around without having the consequence of
affecting your career right all that
matters how big you are I see you're an
actor on the top above the above the
line you can call the shots all day long
NOP not going to do that or people will
cater to you but yeah if you're a little
little little lower on the totem pole
yep okay you're going to do what they
tell you yeah so you know that's where I
think if you're if you're kind of a good
Steward in in all things and you you
don't compromise on your values um as an
actor that's a lot harder because you're
playing a role and there's some people
that say I can't disassociate Who I Am
from the role and if that's the case
honestly don't pursue acting that's not
that's not for you yeah um you know we
have a uh the the college that I went to
um or university that I went to we we
had um we call a passion play every year
where it was the um it kind of starts
with the Last Supper well I guess um
Jesus entering in you know they're
laying the Palm frons goes through the
Last Supper through the crucifixion to
the resurrection and um I remember one
of the college students playing the role
of of Satan when they have that scene
you know where where Satan is trying to
attempt Jesus and and he's praying there
and his disciples are asleep and you
know the the student really got into it
I think did an excellent job of
portraying that role they got a lot of
criticism afterward like are you proud
of that you did that you know and and I
don't know I and this is my own personal
opinion but I think that um to really
show the need of a savior you have have
to properly show the danger of evil and
so you know if that if that actor had
not taken on that role well and really
showed this dark Sinister side of the
enemy the bad guy in that situation then
Jesus would not have looked good you
know I there's a bit of a danger too as
portraying the devil as this little red
C forked you know sort of like
hand deced version of this evil no he's
straight evil and and I you know I think
if we really understood and knew what
the Demonic world or or he was like it
would freak us out I mean it's actually
a blessing we don't know how crazy evil
it is so yeah it's like you know to
portray that in a realistic way um you
know hopefully leaves people with a
cringe you know like but it might be a
price to pay for the the actor cuz
you're right like it needs to take that
on yeah take it on how how do you detach
from that and and you know but also
understand that like let's not idolize
anyone these are not the people that
they're playing so in the same way that
I'm not going to hate the guy that
played the role of the devil I'm also
not going to worship the guy that played
the role of Jesus like they are an
individual and there's the role that
they have to play and I think that
that's something that I've seen people
of Faith struggle with a bit more of
like well you should only play the roles
that are like you and I'm like that's
not acting that's a that's a personality
but it's interesting though there is
that option though cuz I'm sure an actor
or actress comes to mind that every time
you see them it's the same character
over and over in different movies and
and films so U movies and TV shows so
what would you say to that well and that
and those are usually people that kind
of got themselves pigeon hold and they
they did enough of the same roles that
they got to be known for that um
sometimes that's a bad thing sometimes
that's a good thing I think there's
people like like I think of Liam niss
like he's he's embraced the fact that
he's you know like the action hero with
those things and I he seems to be okay
with that so um you know if you do
enough of those yeah you can you can get
into that role if that's not what you're
wanting to do and you're wanting to have
more variety then yeah you do have to be
cautious with what roles you're taking
because you can start to be you know
misconstrued as oh this is the only area
of skill that they have it's interesting
how that works both ways because that's
the case for the actor but it's also the
case for the viewer like do they have
the ability to separate the person from
the character and usually people don't
when they see a celebrity on the street
they'll call them by the character's
name not their actual name so I think
the most important thing for us to do is
to ask God yes is this what you want me
to do yeah is this what you want me to
do and and you know we we all have
opinions of certain things but at the
end of the day our opinion means nothing
God's opinion means everything so you
know his ways are not our ways sometimes
we don't understand his ways just make
sure you ask God that question yeah I
think that's the epitome of God meeting
people where they're at yeah and more
often than not in the stories that I've
heard he's transformed the life of
someone who was already in that space he
didn't call someone completely left
field to go in and be effective in that
way and so that's another thing to keep
in mind some Pastor is like all right I
want you to go start MMA now okay God
there you go doesn't that that's not to
say it doesn't happen but Mighty Weare
yes yes I would agree with you okay so
at this point in your story you're a
producer at in Atlanta in Hollywood
but you don't work in that space anymore
you're in Hope Studios now which is more
religious content so what what happened
what what did that transition look like
for you yeah so uh shortly before covid
um I had I had produced some commercials
and some some short films and stuff with
a production company that I opened and
so I was kind of doing you know
assistant to exec producer work on big
budget stuff and then high level
position producer but on small small
budget stuff so
um I ended up in this conversation with
a um a television network that was
called hope Channel International and
they had been around for about well this
year this last year they just celebrated
uh 20 years um so you know this was what
four years ago or something so around 15
16 years they'd been around and um they
were interested in looking at new
avenues and so I had been in the
industry enough to notice that there was
a completely different model and this is
where I'm thankful for the experiences
that I had because I'm a curious being
and I like to ask questions and so you
know one of the big questions that I had
was I thought this was a Netflix
Universal you name it bigname production
why does my paycheck say like no name
Productions to LLC and I was like what's
what gives like what what's up with that
and they were like oh well that's common
practice you know every time that the
the studio does something they open a a
company they run it through that and
then they can limit all their
liabilities with it it also allows them
to work much faster and more efficiently
and they're essentially a every every
movie is a startup or every show is a
startup company hired and fired yeah and
so they can move with like serious
agility that that a larger organization
that has to protect all of his assets
would have lots of checks and balances
and red tape and committees and sign off
because everything that they do you know
their the whole company's liab is liable
for and so I was like oh that's really
interesting and you know that stuck with
me and so when I had this meeting with
them I said you know if if you want to
start doing those kinds of projects you
have to work a bit more like a film
financing company than an inhouse you
know Production Studio model um because
when you talk about the studios like the
Hollywood Studios that's really what
they are they're they managing
intellectual property that they own um
or that they're acquiring or licensing
and then they're financing the
production to go out and happen and then
they're leveraging their marketing teams
and distribution connections to get
stuff out there but they're not bringing
everyone in and you work for the studio
I mean maybe maybe early Hollywood days
you were owned by the studio but those
days are gone and now they essentially
work as we distribute or we Finance um
so I said you know let's let's look at
that Avenue um and during Co they they
worked on kind of restructuring and so I
got a call just say you know hey um do
you want to come launch this thing hope
Studios and and it's kind of that model
that you laid out a few years ago and so
I said yes and so here we are that's
awesome W that awesome so so give me the
elevator pitch what is Hope studio
trying to do what what how is how is
they are evangelizing can you can you
say that yeah yeah we can say that cuz
cuz we are interested in reaching people
that are
unfulfilled and that can mean a lot of
different things so peaking interest
maybe yeah exactly if you spend time in
the world you're going to realize like
there's broken roads all over the place
right and so you're trying to really
reach the people like hey there's
something better here to offer and um
they might not walk into a church but
they kind of are going to a church we
talk about on our show all the time
that's what the movie theater really is
it's really doing the same
thing a movie is giving you a worldview
people don't look at it like that but
it's giving you a world view how to
dress how to walk how to talk how to do
all that so if you use the format you
can also I I hate to use the word preach
but you're really giving people a sermon
of you know another way of life yeah I
mean I I think every film really well if
it's a good film it's sharing some kind
of point of view it's sharing some
message it's sharing some Human
Experience not every single one of those
has a religious Bend to it not every
single one of those I would say even has
a positive Bend to it um but there is
some Bend to it like I look at I look at
um they're biased yeah look at look at
the Barbie movie right that that
everyone whether you liked it whether
you hated it everybody talked about it
regardless and it was interesting when I
started looking at because there's a lot
of you know analogy to other stuff
within the story line um ultimately it
was asking a question that was
summarized best in the song written for
it by Billy ish which is what am I made
for and that was the question that it
was posing is really a question of
identity and and so you know you may not
say oh well that was a preachy movie
some people actually do because there is
a scene in there where there's whole
monolog that one might call a sermon uh
but you know even even secular films
like they have something that they are
there's a message that they're trying to
convey very intentional in some way or
the other and it's and it's not all good
versus evil on everything sometimes it's
just a different perspective a different
worldview or challenging people to you
know maybe look at hey you've held
strong beliefs in this area like there's
a lot of films that without addressing
theological perspectives are saying hey
maybe you've had a racist view in this
area where you've only viewed one
culture through this lens let me provide
you a different alternative view to that
that maybe just allows you to see
something differently so I think every
film has some kind of a message that
it's trying to convey and and that's
because that's the that's the strongest
Avenue to really convince people where
else will people put their phone down
for 90 minutes or more and pay attention
to your worldview
undistracted I think um some of the
proof that's in the pudding was that
film that came out a few years ago um
that was called unplanned I don't know
if you you saw that um the fact that
they were trying to like stop that from
people seeing it they put a rated R um
viewing on it rating on it because
because of the um abortion scene or or
the or yeah Blood on the floor and a
sonogram of the baby being pulled out
that gave it a rate at R yeah and and
and and so I mean we kind of look at
that and we go that's just absolutely
ridiculous and and they're not playing
Fair because look at all the trash
that's out there right but what they're
doing is they're letting you know how
powerful this stuff really is like it
actually can can change people's
mindsets a single movie and they were
scared that that single movie would have
an impact and so they set it at above
where um somebody should be thinking
about that at 13 14 15 well stranger
things made ego waffles go up in sales
because just taking it out the fridge
yeah she grabbed a whole bunch of them
so so yeah you know I think this this
really speaks to it's a powerful medium
and and and a powerful genre and I think
people get the wrong idea of our work um
a lot of times we we we go around and we
talk about these topics with people and
we are constantly attacking the message
like we're constantly like what message
are you walking away from this thing
rarely we'll talk about the technical
aspect of it but but really it's like
what is this really imbu upon you what
is this leaving you with and and you
know we want people to to focus on that
through the lens of the the Bible like
filter the world around you like like
through that lens right you know kids
ask about like oh fortnite and stuff
like this that's just a little cartoon
we're playing this this game we're
shooting we're not really shooting
anybody and stuff like this yeah but but
in a religious sense like running around
and shooting everybody and be the last
person standing does that really stand
up to your Bible like that kind of stuff
is like what we're trying to like talk
to people about and and do that and
we've had lots of people over the years
talk to us about the film industry what
should I do about this should I go into
this should I not go into this like you
know like they they'll listen to the
message that we have to say and and and
then all of a sudden be like you know
ultimately okay I want nothing to do
with this but we Tinker with with media
90% of our time here all day long if we
were actors we'd make movies too if we
thought it was evil we wouldn't do it we
realized the power of it and and
actually film making is very difficult
it's very very I mean there's a reason
why it's expensive it's much more
expensive to make a film than it is to
make a documentary or whatever like that
so you know mad props to to you know you
guys for really stepping out there and
wanting to um actually have a a a a
different avenue to peque people's
interest with with um with a
relationship with God yeah one of the
goals you stated um for Hope Studios on
the website was to raise the bar for
high quality entertainment with messages
of faith like what does that mean what
does that look
like yeah um well let's let's uh address
the elephant in the room which is when
people say it's a faith-based film
sometimes there's a connotation it's
going to be cheesy it's going to be
preachy it's not going to be good um and
that's partly because you know uh I mean
the industry was very nervous about
doing any kind of Christian content and
it's interesting to see how when they
recognize that there is an audience for
something how they will will swing on
the pendulum and go oh because
ultimately Hollywood I think Hollywood
is interested in making money and if sex
violence and drugs sells they'll do sex
violence and drugs but if value self
they'll actually do values I think
you'll find individuals in there that
have their own agenda but you find that
with any industry and I think each
generation is swinging too you know we
go through this swing of 10 20 years
where we're like oh we're Gra ating
towards this thing and then we realized
you know even with politics and stuff
it's like Democrat Republican so I think
the same thing we're we're starting to
swing into a an area where people are
sick of the disgusting stuff in
Hollywood and they're like we want some
family films and things like that it is
rather refreshing that there's something
being put out there that is that has
actually got some good morals yeah I
mean have you ever sat there and looked
through Netflix and been like what can't
can't can't can't after an hour of that
you're just like forget it I'm going to
bad yeah like the experience of Netflix
is is browsing all the pictures it's
it's really just a reel of thumbnails is
you're like the little pig from a Toy
Story like and it's time to go to bed
all right this is great movie night yeah
because there's no moral content to be
put out so to me it's refreshing to see
someone putting out something that
actually has some some good quality
values to it and and you know I hope and
encourage you guys like you know the
that that God opens up doors with this
kind of stuff well God has been opening
up doors actually God's been kicking
down doors honestly for this it when we
when we started with this the initial
pitch for this was not even that it was
going to go to Cinemas so um the film
let me talk briefly about the film the
film is called the hopeful and it tells
the true story of a group in the mid
1800s that thought the end of the world
was going to happen Now spoiler alert uh
we're all still here the world did not
end but it was it was a pivotal moment
when they had a choice is this going to
be the end chapter of our journey or is
it going to be the beginning and out of
that this revival Was Born That Grew and
expanded into lots of different
countries into lots of different
nationalities to now a 22 million member
movement where one of the leaders was
was uh you know listed as one of the top
uh 100 most influential Americans of all
time by the Smithsonian instit
where you have some of the largest
healthare systems that came out of what
was started there where the original
like vegetarian you know vegan movement
was born out of this and so there's all
these aspects that we still see today
that came from this group of people who
were basically
saying I don't know that what I'm
hearing from religion is truth and so
you had these these Baptists and
Presbyterians and Catholics and
methodists you know all these different
people that were coming together and
saying I want to know truth and I'm not
necessarily convinced that the person at
my Pulpit is telling me the biblical
truth because they're telling me follow
the Bible and then I open the Bible and
I go I don't know that everything I'm
hearing
aligns and so what does that look like
and and so it birthed this movement that
eventually had to organize as a church
um but it it's really the story of that
that movement where it where it came to
be this is same kind of thing a true
story of Revival mid 1800s and so my
hope is you know with all of these these
films that are coming out now that are
sharing messages of faith that we go
okay obey his word and believe there is
no time for
delay I believe the Bible is clear Jesus
will return in but four short years
years I come before you today to tell
you that I have been shown in Vision
father Miller's message was light the
Advent people were traveling on a path
toward a bright and holy
city this is not the first time the end
of the world has been prophesied by a
fool nor will it be the last if you do
not renounce these radical ideas you
will not be welcome here in this house
of
[Music]
worship this was only the beginning of
our journey her visions do not come from
God but my friends she speaks with great
tenderness of the word of the
Lord the Holy Spirit encouraged our
Advent hope there were people who didn't
listen and they fell off the
path really believe this Doctrine which
you preach I was lost and now I'm
found we must follow the word of God
over the rule of
men we feel love the love of Jesus it
lifts us up it carries us
forward and it will guide us
home for
you mhm I mean these people were
studying all night long when was the
last time you stayed up all night long
with your friends and like literally
studied yeah all night yeah I mean
granted they didn't have Netflix and you
know so but they were selling
possessions and they were selling their
farms and they were selling all that
they had and bought into it so you know
when the world didn't end they believed
Christ was going to return and when
Christ did not return that that was
really devastating for a lot of people
and we and we show that in the in the
film and we kind of show you know the
fact that they they come out of that the
next morning and they're being ridiculed
by society and you know yes there there
were things that they got incorrect um
they had assumptions that that were
wrong um and I like the way that one of
the characters phrases it in the film as
he says well let me let me ask you a
question when Jesus was establishing his
kingdom did his own disciples believe it
was a Heavenly Kingdom or an Earthly
Kingdom even understand it and then when
they when he gets resurrected again the
first thing out of their mouth is like
is this the time now and he's just like
oh my goodness and yeah and so despite
that you know Christ was still able to
use all of them to start a movement and
and so we see a similar story here where
people start off with a misunderstanding
and despite that God is able to use that
to start this movement for truth and
what's beautiful about it too is you
really put yourself in this story like
if you really believe something to be
utterly true it's going to happen or
whatever like this and it doesn't what
would that do to your faith is your
faith grounded upon just this idea and I
think that that's why God let a a a
situation like this happen right is is
is really to put in front of us what are
you really believing in this for and so
I think this really hits at the heart of
like you know any Christian I it's not
just one denomination it's any Christian
like what do you do in the way of
something happening that you don't
understand yeah do you truly leave your
your faith on the table or you know how
do you move forward with that so it's
beautiful story I have a question how
how many movies has hope Studios put out
and where do you find these movies that
so this will be the first original
feature film that we're making um and
our stuff can be found you can you can
go to our website if you go to um hop
studios. org you can see the stuff that
we have there but we're intentionally
not just putting it all on one spot
because if we put it all on one place
then that means you're bringing everyone
to you and we want to reach people where
they're at so you know the hopeful will
be in in theaters um you've got some
other series that we worked with um
getting distribution there's a series
called encounters um that we help
facilitate the distribution for and that
went on pureflix um so we're we're kind
of all over the place of saying we want
to get it out as far as possible so you
know you can always see what we're
working on by following any of our
social media if you just go to our
website um hop studios. you can see
stuff there but then um you know where
do you watch it it'll be all over
because that's where people are as
they're all over and we're trying to
reach avenues that maybe some of the
more traditional um things that have
messages of Hope and Faith don't reach
yeah awesome excellent what would you
say to someone young Christian who's a
film Enthusiast they're trying to get
into this this work what advice would
you give uh watch the film um uh and and
I would say watch things with a critical
eye um I you know I I believe that that
you need to know where you are on your
own faith Journey if you're still in
that process of of being molded and not
totally sure on where you stand on your
faith maybe now is a growth time and not
a work time
so take that time learn who you are
learn where you stand on things because
we are called to be in the world but
we're not called to be of it and if
you're still in that place where you're
being shaped by it get out of it find
that space to you know find God in the
quiet learn what you believe know who
you are was it the wal denes I think
that they they spent lots of time like
up in the mountains learning what they
believed and then they went into the
City and they all got jobs in various
IND Industries totally secular they
dressed the same they tried to fit in
the same um but they kept their Bible on
them and when they had the opportunity
they shared that message and so I think
you know kind of looking at history and
saying okay some of the some of the the
the biggest pioneers of faith in this
world globally were people that they
learned who they were first and then
they took that message to the world
because you need to be able to relate to
the world and that's that's the other
caution that I have is when you're there
and you're like okay I'm ready for
mission don't be unrelatable please
don't be unrelatable because you look at
Joseph Joseph is one of the greatest
examples of faith of all time and yet he
was so Egyptian his own Brothers didn't
recognize him that's crazy so he found a
way to assimilate with culture in a way
where he looked sounded felt smelled
probably Egyptian to the point that his
brothers don't recognize him and yet his
faith shines through with the positions
he was entrusted to and saving them from
a famine you know what Paul says too I
speak to the Romans as the Romans do or
whatever um I've often used this too
like there was a time when I couldn't go
to a party without doing drugs or
drinking and and I I don't know if I
separated myself or my friends just
separated themselves from me when I
became a Christian but now I've been
able to be in situations where I'm the
light in that room at a party and and
can you I had a friend that I took the
rehab and right before I took her drugs
broke out all around me and that night
each person I I got to spend oneon-one
time with and and they were like I feel
like you're here for a reason like
you're not doing drugs and like and they
opened up and one guy said I believe
we're in the last days I'm like what it
was it was really crazy and but I don't
recommend somebody else put themselves
in that situation just like I have a
cousin who works with other women and
they go to the strip club and witness to
the strippers but I don't recommend me
or anybody you know other males doing
that so we are all called to do
different things and at different times
in your life too a that's interesting
because they always say like usually 90%
of the time the things that you think
will happen won't happen like the
Terrible Things you think will happen
won't happen and there's a lot of prayer
pressure like you being in that
environment oh I have to take DRS
because you know X Y andz will happen
but you didn't you stood on that
principle and look at the outcome such
positivity it's great well thank you
Kevin so much for coming on the show and
giving these insights um for someone who
would like to watch the hopeful yes when
is that coming out and also if someone
isn't comfortable going to the theaters
where else can they find it so you know
um I I would I would say to the people
that that aren't comfortable with the
idea of oh we're going to theaters we're
going to Cinemas um I I I want to speak
to that person real quick and just say
you know when we when we started
evangelism work um the radio was of the
devil right and then we reclaimed it and
then oh the television the big bad
television was of the devil and then we
reclaimed it there's been millions of
baptisms because of
televangelism and now we have the cinema
and you know that's something I think we
can reclaim for God and when I say
reclaim that I I actually mean reclaim
it like quite literally in the sense
that and this is something we found out
more recently every screen that we put
the hopeful on they have to kick out a
Disney a Paramount a universal movie we
didn't know this we we didn't know this
when we were doing this um no but it was
it was cool to to to find that out
because I was like wow this this just
gave this even more meaning for what
we're doing because even if you don't
feel like the film I mean my prayer is
that it takes takes people a step
forward but even if nothing else you
know we're called to be salt and we're
called to be light and light is out
there it's shining it's very apparent
it's you know breaking through darkness
and all that and salt isn't always as
attractive we love to talk about the
ministries of light but sometimes salt
is just there to slow the Decay and so
it's really interesting when we found
out you know that that all the major
Studios essentially lock down the
screens it's it's essentially like they
own the house and they can rent it out
to other people because they know that
they have so many things coming and so
whenever a new film comes in you have to
make the case that you're going to bring
more Revenue to the the cinema chain
than that other one and so they have to
actively tell the Disney Booker hey
haunted mansion's out because this film
The hopeful is in wow so when I say
reclaim it you know if you're on the
fence about this just please please
consider that please consider that this
is a way to bring someone into a space
that may not be comfortable with the
church but is comfortable with a theater
and that will go in and will put their
phone down and pay attention for 90
minutes and my My Hope Is that you will
be there alongside them to answer the
questions that they may have when
they're done because this film is not
here to provide answers it's here to
inspire questions so if you want to see
the film um you know and depending on
when you're coming across this video
because you may come across it several
years later and it's on streaming
platforms or wherever else just if you
go to the hopeful movie.com it will
continue to be updated with showtimes
and theaters it'll be updated with where
you can find it on streaming or DVDs or
you know maybe in the future you're
watching this on VR who knows right but
yeah if you go to the hopeful movie.com
you can find out all the information
there W all right fantastic well thank
you if you want to see something hopeful
yes here you go fantastic you want to
see other stuff you can go to hop
studios. org and see what we're doing
there and people can contact the studios
all that fantastic and if you like to
connect with any of us Little Light
Studios you can go to little studios. TV
there you can find our documentaries you
can find lightwear which is our t-shirt
brand and a lot of other things so there
are a lot of resources out there that
you can capitalize on to involve
yourself in evangelism in a lot of
creative ways so we thank you so much
for watching LED live and we'll see you
next time have a good weekend bye-bye if
you're looking for good wholesome
educational content for your children
subscribe to our new channel little like
[Music]
kids
oh
[Music]